withholding ammunition from his
fighters.
CNN's nic Robertson is in
eastern Ukraine with details.
>> [Speaking non-english]
>> Translator: Russia's top
Murray is turning a Moscow
again.
With a vengeance.
>> [Speaking non-english]
>> Wagner boss, yevgeny
prigozhin, screaming at
president Putin's defense
minister, and army chief of
staff, accusing them of killing
his troops in bakhmut by
starving them with ammunition.
>> [Speaking non-english]
>> Translator: We are pulling
out of bakhmut.
We have only two or so
kilometers left to capture of
the 45.
>> Hours later, and ultimatum.
Send ammo or he will pull his
troops out of bakhmut.
Just as they are close to
taking it.
>> [Speaking non-english]
>> Also, troubling for the
Kremlin.
Prigozhin hired mikael --
as a Wagner deputy commander.
Until last week, he was
Russia's deputy defense
minister.
Ahead, set a pending Wagner
Kremlin burrow down.
Ukraine says that bakhmut could
be at a turning point if Russia
doesn't fix its ammunition
supply problem.
He also says that prigozhin
cannot afford to continue
losing troops at this rate.
If he does, the spokesman says,
Faulkner will be destroyed.
Prigozhin, he says, has no
option but to pull out.
[Sound of artillery]
>> Prigozhin's machinations
have no impact on the fighting
around the devastated city.
Friday, both sides still
feeding men into the front
lines.
Knows as Ukraine's meat
grinder.
And the fighting, not just on
the battlefield, in Turkey, a
Russian diplomat rips down the
Ukrainian flag, but it's
quickly punched at a
parliamentary assembly intended
to get both sides to agree an
extension to the U.N. Brokered
black sea grain deal.
[Speaking non-english]
Russia's diplomats also hitting
out at the United States.
Deputy foreign minister, sergei
Reiber cough, announcing the
U.S. And Russia are on the
verge of open armed conflict.
A further escalation of recent
unsubstantiated Kremlin
rhetoric, claiming that united
States directed Ukraine to fly
drones over the Kremlin in an
attempt to assassinate
president Putin.
An allegation both Kyiv and
Washington categorically deny.
Nic Robertson, CNN, eastern
Ukraine.
>> All right, let's talk more
about what's happening at the
Kremlin beyond Steve hall.
Ppening at the>> He's joining us right now.
He's a national security
analyst and former CIA chief of
Russia operations.
Steve, great to see you.
I mean, what do you think the
Wagner commander is doing here?
I mean, it would seem suicidal
that he would be so outspoken
and critical of the Kremlin
like this.
>> Yeah, let's start with what
he's not doing.
He's not really mourning his
troops.
He has no great concern for
those courses that were piled
around him in that particular
video.
He is the one espousing these
meat grinder tactics.
He is not making a plea out of
the humanitarian park.
What he's doing is power play.
He's seeing how far he can
extend his power into today's
Russia, and it's surprising
that Putin is giving him, in my
view, as much running room as
he has.
But you have to understand the
way the Russians system works
is extremely byzantine.
A lot of it goes on behind
closed doors.
A lot of it, Putin stands back
and it's a dog eat dog, last
man standing, and they are all
men.
Last man standing kind of thing
to determine who the next wave
of leadership is going to be.
Prigozhin might be making a
play for that.
>> But it seems like it would
be embarrassing for the Kremlin,
because it's exposing some real
vulnerabilities in the group
that it has been leaning on,
particularly in bakhmut.
>> Yeah, it is a little bit of
a stretch.
It will be interesting to see
how Putin handles this, but you
know, the other thing is,
there's not a whole lot of room
for Putin to maneuver in here.
You've got a losing situation
on the battlefield.
If they, indeed, if prigozhin
follows through on his threat
and pulls his forces out,
really, regardless of whether
those forces come back in, it
could be a big setback for
bakhmut and Russia on the
battlefield, which is, indeed,
embarrassing to Putin.
But you know, he doesn't have a
whole lot of options left.
It's not working with the
current military leadership or
the former generals that he's
had.
So, I think to a certain extent,
Putin is trying to figure out
what the next move is here.
It's just not a lot of good
ones.
>> Okay.
Then, let's talk about that
alleged drone attack.
Moscow's implicating the U.S..
And Ukraine, in that drone
attack on the Kremlin this
week.
Or, in your view, is this
another case of some Russian
anti war, anti Kremlin group?
That is trying to shake up the
Kremlin?
>> Yeah, that's another
fascinating question.
So, first of all, I'm not a big
believer or subscriber to the
theory that this is a Russian
false flag operation, that they
did this themselves.
That really shows weakness, if
you can't protect your own
airspace around the Kremlin,
and really, does Putin need any
further excuse to shoot more
Ukrainians or launch more
artillery?
Now.
Is there this set of groups,
groupings of partisans or
guerrillas inside of Russia?
There are actually striking out
against Russia infrastructure,
Russian government.
Things have been blowing up
recently, besides the stuff
that was happening over the
Kremlin.
You've had fuel depots.
You had a very nationalistic
war blogger, who was attacking
a car bomb, recently, who did
that.
You do have to ask, and I think
the Kremlin is probably asking,
do we have a problem inside of
Russia that isn't necessarily
Ukraine?
The fsb, the internal
intelligence service, would be
in charge.
They are usually very good at
something out and finding if
there's in the groups trying to
operate against the Kremlin.
But, yeah that's, or something
else.
Something off Putin at the
worry about, Fred.
>> At the same time, Russia is
good about staging things,
right?
I mean, is it at all possible,
when you have Russia's deputy
foreign minister, warning this
week of the U.S. And Russia are
on the verge of open armed
conflict?
I mean, is it looking for a
reason to poke at the bare, so
to speak?
Try to get things started
between the U.S. And Russia?
>> Yeah, --
it's very, very.
Good he understands the west
very well, especially the
United States.
He understands that when the
Kremlin starts making
accusations against the united
States or other nato partners,
they are actually the ones who
are responsible for all this,
that we get nervous and we
start talking about oh my
goodness, have we back Putin
into a corner?
That's what they're hoping to
do with this.
I think the other thing going
on is there anticipating a
counteroffensive from the
Ukrainians to all of us are,
and if it doesn't go well for
the Russians, I think the line
from Putin and the Kremlin is
going to be well, we would have
finished off the Ukrainians,
had it not been for the
Americans who were the ones who
were really fighting against
here.
So, I think they're setting up